[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
me feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Emmett's and Soho where I'm joined
by mayhem Lauren his latest project gems
from the equinox with DJ Muggs it's
available now you're known from his role
in vice LANs [ __ ] that's delicious we're
a week over week you can see him eating
his way around the globe with his buddy
Action Bronson but today there are only
two towns in the world that really
matter the Windy City and the Big Apple
we're here at Emmett's one of the few
places in the five boroughs where you
can get authentic deep-dish style pizza
to settle an age-old debate where does
one find the better food New York City
or Chicago now mayhem your Queens till
the death of you hundred percent I have
some biases of my own but I'm coming in
this with an open mind I'm ready to have
a very reason to be you know I'm Pro
Chicago anybody you can catch me in a
Jordan Jersey at any given some added
mix game it's nothing you guys have done
a [ __ ] that's delicious episode in
Chicago what's your foundation what do
you think of the food they're not
Chicago's a good food city that
definitely top five possibly the top
three and I want to say my favorite
place in Chicago we didn't go to one
[ __ ] that's delicious
it's the purple pig and shout out to the
purple pig any chance I get a slide off
and I get that turkey leg alright so
here's the main event it's the food
debate that has caused black eyes and
hurt feelings for centuries it's the New
York Pizza
first the chicago-style deep-dish bring
in the pizza
deep dish style pizza all the cheese
that you have in the kitchen two inches
thick piled high with toppings and well
you might get killed for eating a New
York style slice with a fork and a knife
sometimes a deep-dish it's the only
option sometimes but not now oh right
now it's me and you I'm me and my man
showing the chill and if I was on our
hot date and I don't want to make a mess
of myself maybe I pull out a knife and
fork to pretend to be civilized
look I'm chilling with my man we're
about to pick this up and jump right
into it hope it needs enhancement
crushed red zone everything it's just
the way I was raised
takes me back flawless it's a beautiful
thing right there and that's a big deal
for a New Yorker to concede that people
always want to not Chicago by
classifying it as something else no no
everyone who rides for New York is
always like deep-dish isn't real pizza
it's lasagna it's a casserole but think
about it if you're sitting down at a
table would you rather have this plate
pop in front of you or this plate plop
in front of you I think that nine out of
10 people gunned ahead if they're being
real about it if you hook them up to a
lie-detector test would say this plate
it's just it really depends on how you
feel like today right I have a busy day
I have a million things to do I don't
want to eat this right now because I
won't be able to move after that some
days you want to put on air maxes some
days you want to put on a Gucci sneaker
they're both great it just depends on
how you're feeling many times I've been
shirtless in the Thompson hotel ordering
blue Mouse staring at the window
reflecting on life
the new york-style slice it's wider it's
thinner you eat it with a crease down
the middle it's portable it's light on
sauce it's heavy on cheese all right I'm
gonna take a bite of this New York slice
now this one's from Jose Jose makes
great New York style pizza but what's
your go-to New York job shout out to
Danny's house a pizza and a special
semi-sweet sauce they also have a pesto
slice I usually get one on one with the
order of baked clams go to Danny's sweet
sauce pesto baked clams it's over as a
New Yorker what's the perfect slice
what's a slice that breaks the main
ingredient in a New York slice is 100%
the sauce anybody can melt cheese
although it's what's in between that
makes it breaks a slice here's to me but
also make Chicago pizza special is the
leftovers are just as good if not better
than when they're served oven fresh at
the restaurant I feel the same thing
about in New York slice some time you
wake up put it back in the oven it's
extra crispy
you might even grow some peppers onions
and throw them on top if you feel a
fancy in the morning you know what I
mean same thing all right before we turn
the page on pizza and put a bow on the
episode we have a little pizza bonus you
know Chicago it might be famous for the
deep-dish some people might be surprised
to know that it does thin crust almost
just as well ready for this one so you
never have to talk me into a look at
this already that's how you time it up
there are boys this is the Silent
Assassin from Chicago the little-known
Chicago style thin crust pizza
well first glance you can see there's
really not like an outer crust like
you'd you see on like the typical New
York slice right cheese goes all the way
to the end then you see it's kind of cut
into squares if I pick up a slice you
don't mind me doing go for it it's
cracker thin right you can actually hear
it crack it's like a piece of matzah
right they record thin yeah Mazel Tov
hold on hold one I feel bad man I got my
man in the cut your mugs come through
man take a slice of it they brought out
the bonus pie you got to eat
or mugs cheers Cheers
it's how we break bread Cheers
this is very like you win a championship
and Little League you win some sort of
basketball tournament team going out for
pizza afterwards it's this style I would
say most pizzerias in Chicago serve this
and this is what we kind of grew up with
so you just made that for Taurus right
down to the bills man just shake down
the visitors idea they got me I'm hooked
all right table cleared this experiment
decide is Chicago a better food city
than New York and your opinion or no not
New York is the best food city in the
world so many options too much to offer
it's Queens alone is the most culturally
the first place in the world is just no
city can prepare to New York and you're
hearing that from mayhem on YouTube so
you know it's gospel gems from the
equinox catch it
[ __ ] that's delicious you already know
Caesars Riesling the way sorry no you
know I gotta jump in and spit that out
close them together man of Chicago New
York things slow
[Music]
you